hey man say man what it do it's the
freestyle king lil flip aka flip
mayweather check me out on the bootleg
cave podcast exotic pop yiddi oh look
boulette cap show special guest we have
got the h-town legend himself
little flip in the building man welcome
bro
welcome welcome hey
what's good bro i love the place man
thank you better yeah man congrats on
everything thank you man how's
everything going with you been blessed
how you doing i can't complain hey i
woke up today so yeah i tell everybody
that's a hell of a great start that is a
great start
first of all what's going on like what's
the latest and greatest in little flips
world what are you what have you been
doing what have you been working on i
know you always got businesses you're
starting and all kinds of [ __ ] going on
right yeah i mean that's that's all i do
um
let's see besides being the owner of
exotic pop
which is everywhere everywhere
dad um i'm doing a lot of stuff in the
metaverse i got a concert coming up in
the metaverse
um
august 14th
and then me and zero we just got done
with kings of the south part too
i dropped flip mayweather
um
i got a
well i guess i'll i'll announce it here
okay i got a show coming where we're
going to discover the next
big
thing like a talent like a reality show
yes yes and we want
the next you know like it's always one
of ones but
legendary stuff we're not looking for
regional we're not looking for we want
the next stadium filler what is what is
uh the platform that it'll be on well
that's the thing that that's the only
thing that we're you're gonna film it
first and then shop it around or well we
already have things in place already
yeah yeah man shout out to king lee you
know my business partner but we got some
stuff going so
the metaverse the apps the exotic pops
how did you get involved with exotic pop
well the other owner charleston he's
from houston okay and um
he grew up on my music we grew up in the
same area and
he was like man i got the soda company
thing i'm doing
what's up and so
i'm like man i'm down and so we just put
our hairs together and keeling and the
cool cup juice and we just been
yeah cause like uh any
smoke shop you go into or i mean
obviously liquor stores too there's
right because because exotic pop quickly
form all you guys are giving like
artists their own sodas right correct
right right right give him
like
other streams of income right um what
some of the artists that have their own
soda i know mac dre's got his when i was
in the bay we tried it yeah recipes that
that's one of my favorite ones the
bubble gum okay um rest a piece of mac
dre um
man we did well with uh rob kardashian
we did one with drake's dad
21 savage and metro boomin yeah
we gave sauce walker his own water i got
um cream soda and i have a green apple
cool cup juice
man there's so many artists man but
the legends like dj screw big mo
um fat pad like all the legends who are
not here big hawk
you know we help their families with
with the money and each
soda that we sell like on the back of it
it says like a percentage of it goes to
the community so wherever the artists
are from we do a lot of stuff with the
community with the kids
and um i'm actually
putting out a mixtape august 14 called
the art of freestyle where i'm rapping
over my favorite big mo beats oh [ __ ] my
favorite fat pet beat so i sat down with
d wreck
the owner of all these masters and i'm
like hey bro you got them cleared yes
i'm like bro i i want to rap on
these classic beats and put them out and
you know so we talked about the biz but
it's crazy you know
because i feel like the people who came
before me it's on me
to make sure while i'm still here that
their names live on you know what i mean
because they did so much for me
and you know we nobody knows when we go
go so it's on me it's on flip everywhere
i go to make sure
dj screw
pmc big mo hulk fat pat like all these
different people
that are from where i'm from
that we hold to high regard same way
people hold big and pop like or even
like a guy like mac dre in the bay
exactly so you know we just we go keep
pushing it
how did you initially because i remember
when you came out
the first thing i remember was you
having your own cereal with the
leprechaun
project and then obviously
it was like oh [ __ ] there's this guy
who's got his own cereal i was living in
arizona at the time so i didn't know
much about
the houston scene outside of like rap a
lot and scarface and um obviously ugk
they're from port arthur but uh but in
terms of like the screwed up [ __ ]
um just that whole kind of wave
i really didn't get super hip too until
you know it really went
commercial and you know when you and
mike jones and paul and everybody had
their uh
their wave you know
so how did you like initially kind of
get into the game and like
i know like nationally was that kind of
like your first big look the the
leprechaun [ __ ]
yeah well the leprechaun was my first um
solo album so
the difference is one of the other
reasons why i call myself phillip
mayweather
is because i'm born into music just like
he was born into boxing
so a lot of artists they started rapping
and doing music as you know 15 high
school you know like if you're born in
my house you doing music gotcha so
i already knew the industry i sung in
the rapt did talent shows used to rap
battle
play the piano
drums learning the guitar
was in film
acting class etiquette class media
training so i was already
ready right for the industry man and um
the leprechaun i put that out after i
did a group album called hsc which
stands for hustler stacking ins but
prior to that i had a few other groups
that i was in that i started
and um
man i just knew if
i had a person like jay prince and rap a
lot by the way free larry hoover he did
yeah like if i had somebody like that as
my mentor in my same city to
study the blueprint
so i just said back like okay
this the way you
you market yourself just the way you
don't take no for answers this is the
way you invest in your own money and
time you do it your way so
seeing them come through you know clubs
and come through the neighborhoods in
the in the double lars and the rolls
royces like since i was young and
watched richie rich i already knew
rose rushes was for me right right
chatting on me somewhere i don't know
the double i was right here
the logo but um
so
i had the perfect blueprint to watch how
rap a lot
you know like this man had a car lot and
then turned it into like
music business and
you know had the ghetto boys everywhere
and just different artists and and
putting out these albums and coming to
car shows displaying all their cars and
showing up to the shows 50 deep
everybody all in black like it was just
like a big thing
so i basically was a sponge
being able to balance what i learned
from my family my dad my grandparents
my mom and then dj screwed
then it was like i was learning from jay
prince as well so
we put out the hse album put that out
rest in peace to jason he died he's on
hsc album my high school homie and um
then after that when we when we put it
offense was like man we wanted a flip
solo album why would you put the group
out and you're the hottest thing in the
streets
but
i've always been one of them people that
like to try to bring people with me
right and i mean that was how i was
raised like if you have more than the
next person
hey i'm not gonna sit and eat a steak
and you don't have nothing i just cut my
[ __ ] in half and give you half of my
steak like i'm that's the type of person
i am and so
i did that
and that was one of the best decisions
because it allowed me to record the
leprechaun album
and what happened the first album we put
out the group album hsc we did pretty
cool you know what i mean but it was so
many people on the label the amount of
money that it was making
and then i'm the marquee artist it just
wasn't
enough right and everybody wants to see
me right so it's like i'm like but i
still want my my guys like with me you
know i mean so
the leprechaun album i wrote half of it
and i freestyle half of it
and half of that album like i was like
literally still in the trap with my
homie taz rest in peace to test that's
my guy
um
like literally making the album making
plays
you know in the front room
you know with the shotgun you know in
the front room with the nato aka like
like literally making plays and in
between playing
you know playstation and writing reps
and and constructing my leprechaun album
so
i was able to really have fun and i can
do that it was a single we put that [ __ ]
out yeah it did crazy did that come out
on rap a lot no no that was just
straight yeah i partnered up with a guy
named hump and we we we um
well sucker free was like a concert it
was entertainment company at first and i
partnered up with him because he was one
of my childhood i remember that i
remember the psycho free [ __ ] yeah my so
my dad he was one of my dad's childhood
friends and
i'm like all right hey let's turn it to
a record label you be the ceo i'd be the
ceo and so we put it out did well
independent
and
a lot of people don't know when you put
out a double album it count it's twice
two yeah right so like people like
you know pock and biggie when they you
know they go down life after death all
that yeah they sold five yeah five
minutes but it counts as two it counts
as two so
eight ball
you know one of my he had the triple
album yeah the triple album because i
lost so
i'm like damn all he got to sell is one
third of half a meal and it's platinum
and he's go you know what i mean oh yeah
yeah true true yeah yeah yeah yeah to
get the gold plaque yeah yeah so it's
like
and it ended up selling you know million
plus so he ended up going triple
platinum a lot of people don't know
about lost is like triple platinum
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah so in my mind
i'm like i i'm a sponge so i studied rap
a lot i study suave house i study
everything and then i implement my own
you know
final version of what i've learned from
everybody put that [ __ ] out so a lot of
record was doing mixtape a lot of
records
mixtape mixtapes pulling out everybody
was like why are you rapping on these
beats and putting them out you should
focus on real stuff
i'm like nah this is what dj schrute
taught me this is where i come from so
people started seeing we would pull up
the times and
we picking up show money and hell i'm
picking up mixtape money
the mixtape money hell at times was
two times more than the show money so
i'm dropping off boxes five you're just
like dropping off at the local spots
music mania was a spot in austin
crazy place it was
a record store yes bro right next to
active athlete and bro i pull up
cash out 15k here 20k here
damn good old days yeah come back to
austin three months later
by that time i got a new mixtape out
repeat so i had a place in austin a
place in dallas uh t-time music a place
in tyler
wow those were like my main three hubs
of where i knew i could go pick a 5k
here 10k here dropping off some product
well it was the easiest [ __ ] and so i'm
like y'all calling me stupid but
y'all wondering how i'm selling all
these records and how everybody wants to
see me is because i'm just giving this
[ __ ] away
sometimes we were selling them as well
so like at the to the retail people i
would sell them to them but at the
concepts i would give them away um right
that's crazy hey
those are the good old days though man
hell yeah when you could sell
you could just pull up and have like a
relationship with the owner of a record
store and
you know he believe in what you're doing
and then
you turn that into instant monetary
mm-hmm
it's crazy what the streaming [ __ ] is
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our partners our
family at odd socks go to
oddssoxofficial.com
right now
and the promo code bootleg kev it'll get
you 20 off the fly of socks in the world
[ __ ] spongebob
[ __ ] cheez-its
a little bit of pepsi
uh how about how about some underwear do
we like underwear e.t boxers let's go
ahead and just open up a pair of these
boys
so you can see how fly the draws are
ladies and gentlemen because they are
fly by the way they just gave me my own
pair of odd socks go on my social media
and you could see them uh i don't know
if they're gonna be for sale
because let's be honest
who wants to wear socks with my [ __ ]
ugly face on them besides my wife and
she don't even wanna wear them there we
go
they got the draws they got it all man
get the odd socks basics which i love
just the basic boys these are amazing
comfy socks
oddssocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev save 20 off let's get back
to the interview have you have you had
any issues like adjusting to the
streaming world or do you feel like it
benefits artists like you that's
independent that can just kind of drop
freely if you will
man i'm one of them people like this bro
i'm like uh
i'm not a stuck in my ways type of king
right i hustle the dinosaur way
the modern way
and the future way so
it i mean i love it i just embrace it i
still press up my physical copies and my
wax for the djs that like wax and wax
sales for pretty good money these days
so yeah people still buy vinyl it's like
almost like as a collector they'd almost
rather buy the vinyl than the cd because
it feels like
there's people buying vinyl don't even
have a turntable to play it on they just
want to have it agreed agreed and um
so yeah that's that's where i met and
then like the things with the streams
you know like
like i say the only downfall to the
stream you know like i'm not i'm not one
of them og haters like uh
i'm like i [ __ ] with the new cats the
new artist you know my only concern with
the streams is like this i compare right
i compared a stream to this
you know how back in the days you could
go to a music store and listen to the
whole album yeah you should go to sam
goody and right you can jam it whatever
whatever all right if you didn't buy it
you didn't get that sale right like the
pro the artist didn't get that sale so
if you go to a car lot and you test
drive a car
and you don't buy it the guy who's
selling the car doesn't get credit
for you test driving the car right he
gets credit for yourself so just the way
that they converted to like yeah this
many streams this means you're platinum
right but
a sample to me is still not it's like
you can't lower the goal post that's how
i look at it no matter where no matter
what right like any other business if
you sell pizza
if you only sell 20 pizzas man you only
sold 20 pizzas well if you think about
it like with the playlist world it's
like you might throw a new playlist on
that spotify feeds you whether it's like
rap cabbie or whatever
and even if the song plays for 30
seconds you don't [ __ ] with you hit next
on the playlist it still counts as a
stream right so it's it it's like a
sometimes a person that's able to be
like oh yeah i went platinum i got this
many streams and it creates a big head
like a lot also like you'll really know
if it's working if you can sell hard
tickets correct because there's a lot of
these artists who stream big numbers but
they can't go on tour yeah so it's so
it's so
like i'm like on the fence with like
just like a hundred percent like oh i
love it like it's dope that people all
around the world can hear your music
from the push of a button but when you
can also upload [ __ ] exactly
so it's kind of exactly back in the day
you had to go press up cds find
distribution right to get like your [ __ ]
all over the country in a record store
agreed man so now it's like i just hit
there's no middleman yeah so like
i embrace it i'm one of them people i
adapt man what's going on you know plex
like i love i love like in my house and
my studios i got plaques and
stuff on the wall that just inspires me
man you know what i mean so
i [ __ ] with this setup though man you uh
the first like like i guess your kind of
coming out party would you say would be
like underground legend in terms of just
like commercially national
correct
was was game over on that
game over was on the the next album
right you got to feel me the way we ball
was the first gotta feel me was crazy
this is the way yeah i forgot about the
way we go one video mochi platinum off
one video that's [ __ ] crazy because
was that a double album yeah yeah all my
albums are double albums i remember it
most of the time what was the album
where you were like kind of like in
black on the cover it came out at the
game over remix was on there i wanted to
see mine that [ __ ] was there was a
record on there
[ __ ] that i loved because i know that
like
that was kind of there wasn't like a
super smash on that album was there it
would not it
i wouldn't say it was a super special
there was a record on that project that
i [ __ ] loved yeah it was like i think
i put what it do was on there with manny
fresh and yeah we put we put a little
money behind it but we didn't go home i
didn't mind there was a couple of
records on there that i i loved and that
was the part right there i was actually
like transitioning and leaving the label
so one that's why it's like a a version
where it's one cover of me standing in
front of black and then it's one version
when i went to uh yeah warner brothers
i'm holding some money and some quick
[ __ ] i didn't really like that cover but
i put on the cover free zero so that's
what i was pushing you know
so welcome home zero he been out for me
been home for a while yeah yeah but i
did that they were like
you're going to put free somebody on
your album cover i'm like yeah
this is warner yeah yeah well this was
sony
no no this was one this was one just one
person one person asked me and i was
like um
yeah they're like it's not a mixture
listen i know what i'm doing
like see i never let a person like
tell me what i can or can't do
especially when it comes to art i'm one
of those people though i will listen to
your opinion like i would listen like
i'm a that doesn't mean i have to take
it but i will acknowledge it and if it
makes sense to me i'm a rock away of
course yeah that's how i can open the
input open information that's how i got
where i'm at yo um there was a period of
time
where you were popping up on a lot of
june at radio [ __ ] the mixtapes back in
the day was there ever uh any
conversations where 50 was trying to
sign you the g unit man me and 50 we
talked about doing some business um a
few times um it never like happened like
i think mainly due to like scheduling
and stuff but we didn't specifically
talk like on signing to because he
no matter
if i'm on tv or not like i'm i came in
this industry as a ceo so if i would
ever do a deal with another artist it
would be a joint partnership it would be
a partnership i'll never ever be under
anybody and never have uh every album i
ever put out i was the ceo so i was
already taught as a kid come in a game
of ceo be an artist don't let people
tell you oh you should just focus on
the music part and let us talk for you
and know that's how you get robbed
that's how lawyers put that's how you
get those shitty deals bro that's how
lawyers man finesse you out of breathe
especially the lawyers that like are
suggested to you by the people you're
signing to oh you don't have a good
lawyer we got one for you yeah bro
they're [ __ ]
so
i'ma talk for myself i get to done i get
the deal done way quicker when i talk
for myself did you ever have a situation
where you got into a shitty deal like
early on like whether it was the sony or
the warner situation because back in the
day those major label deals were [ __ ]
treacherous thank god i never got into a
shitty deal i've been in some deals
where
i got what i wanted i got what i asked
for but
i looked out for somebody out of what i
got right only to find out later that
they had got
a separate bag for themselves as well so
they dipped in they double dipped they
double dip but i still got what i want
because at the end of the day i think
like a hustler
i get paid to talk
sing make words rhyme come up with witty
[ __ ] make a [ __ ] say wow
it's people that talk all day they don't
that don't get paid for so i look at it
like this bro
any amount of money that a [ __ ]
gonna pay me just a talk is a win
now when we go to my accolades and what
i've accomplished i know how to find a
medium of
i know how to negotiate my dad was a
master car salesman so i know how to
play a sheep i know how to play a wolf
because at the end of the day i'm a
hustler so
at the end of the day almost any amount
of money that's respectful respectable
is not getting [ __ ] over you see what
i'm saying but yeah i've always
known how to speak my mind because i
grew up around older people i'm i'm the
youngest in the screwed up clique but
i'm not afraid to speak my mind if o.g
or somebody did something to me that i
feel like they slighted me and it was
wrong i'm going to address it now i know
how to approach it respectful you see
what i'm saying i'm not i'm not a
reckless you know gee you know [ __ ] like
that but
i'm not afraid to speak my mind and i'm
a very honorable person when being from
screwed up click and i kind of feel like
you were a little bit ahead slightly
ahead
of the of the of the kind of like
h-town
national craze i kind of feel like you
were like probably the first dude in
that class of
like of your peers that really popped
correct
i'm talking like obviously you know the
chamillionaires of paul walsh you were
kind of first i i was first yeah i i was
i was the first person like out of
that wave you know we had latroy he went
platinum right but i just mean in terms
of just the ti i feel like the age
racket yeah
yeah yeah but i was just saying you know
yeah
i want to be a ballerina yeah we had
that like right before like the the
[ __ ] started going on you know but um
yeah yeah definitely i was i was first
was there ever any uh
was there ever any like because swisher
house had kind of you know uh
michael 5000 watts was
chopping and screwing [ __ ] as well was
there ever any sort of static between
the screwed up [ __ ] and the swisher
house [ __ ] it was
well and it like because obviously
everyone ends up on that source cover
right which was a crazy cover right
right the the don't mess with texas
everybody and their mom was on that
cover right um but uh did that like like
like what was what was like your take on
like seeing swisher house come out and
kind of obviously you know dj screw
started chopping and screwing [ __ ] but
it also was like a houston thing as much
as it was his thing that he created you
know um
but what what was your take on the
swisher house movement you know kind of
being on the other side of things
i'm in a screwed up click so
like
i'm an understandable person you know i
mean so a lot of members was like oh
[ __ ] what is that what's going on
they're doing what we doing and my whole
take i just feel like hey man we
inspired some people to to do what they
do you know i mean so i didn't look at
it
you know like some of the other members
looked at it you know you had some
people that was like they didn't like it
and you had some people that was like
hey man [ __ ]
they expressing they self they they want
to you know what i mean we motivated
some people to you know what i mean
so that's how i always looked at it and
that's one of the reasons i'm the first
person
out the screwed up click to go do a
freestyle on the swisher house
so i got clap my biggest freestyle
is on a swisher house tape which
freestyle was that it's uh it's a
mixtape called i-45 and um
um it's a record like we blow in though
i might be on jay leno they be like flip
can you listen to my demo i say nah
[ __ ] i got shows to do after the
concert i got hoes to screw like that's
a classic freestyle that's like
[ __ ] scream that [ __ ] like word
for word and um so i was always going
over there i got family that's on the
north side so
in the midst of the north side and south
side beef i was always on the offside
anyway like
because i don't i don't at the end of
the day the way i feel we houston right
i mean at the end of the day it's about
unity for me so
you know yeah my biggest freestyle is on
the swiss shots tape that's crazy and
i'm i'm in the screwed up clip what can
you tell us about uh that
uh source magazine cover was everyone
there at the same time yep
what was that like it was a great day i
played dominoes with jay prince um
senior
and uh
we was on a ranch you know that was one
of the inspirations to me you know
buying a ranch and cattle
um so just being on the ranch and
hearing about the ranch and just being
there because what was on that cover of
his face bro slim
pow
commander millionaire
pimp c bumby
chingo
i don't think he was on the cover i
think he was on the inside yeah you had
to open it oh you had to open it yeah
okay because it was it was the cover it
was like one of those fold-outs
i still have the magazine
damn but i remember him being there yeah
because like the ones i got i got i
still got some copies of it in my studio
but that particular one i don't think
maybe he was on the old side maybe i
don't remember yeah i think it was the
inside but but yeah everybody was there
bro it was a cold day
that's what i had on the fur it was a
cold ass [ __ ] day and um
we did some kind of like pastor mike
freestyle that same day too it was cool
man i mean
it was cold was it probably the last day
that all those people were together all
at once huh man
when you put it like that probably so
it's a lot of people to get yeah yeah
probably so because we lost pmc long
live pmc yeah smoke sound [ __ ] in
memory of pmc
yeah that was a that was a big moment
because i just it encapsulated just kind
of
right the movement that was going on at
the time definitely uh
why do you think that movement
didn't have a lot of longevity
commercially because it felt like there
was like a three or four year window
where it was like it and then it kind of
just started to you know
i don't know if it was g unit you know
running with [ __ ] or it just just hip
hop kind of shifted shifted right
um i know part of the reason
is
what's the word evolving right
every coast every town has their own
lingo their own slang words that they
say things that they do
so for us you know the candy paint the
double cups the diamond teeth
that's us right that's our culture like
we live it's in us it's not a fad for us
right so
sometimes a fad for the rest of the
country right so yeah to sum up yeah
they thought it was a fad and so
everybody started getting grills where
they're talking you know funny can't
really talk and just
you know double cups all this stuff that
we started and um
so man it's just like some people didn't
want to keep hearing about candy paint
popping trunks grills you know what i
mean
and then um
at the same time
some artists like
okay if you make a record that's
about a certain topic right and it it
it goes you know gold or whatever the
case may be pretty you know plenty
fanfare
you're gonna
replicate that people are gonna be in
your ear
you need another one of those right so
then you go back in the studio and you
try to make another one of those back
then yeah right so it's like you're
probably on your head like we need
another sunshine right right and and me
i'm just like listen i'm going to create
it it has to happen organically did they
ever try to force you in to do a ashanti
record back then like a record with her
yeah because sunshine was so big like at
the same time like ashanti's on like you
know everything everything not they
didn't they never forced a shanty record
i was able to do one with beyonce i did
naughty girl yeah you did the naughty
girl oh my god i forgot about that and
then i did a remix with uh kelly rowland
can't can't nobody and um
i hate that record didn't do what it
shoulda did
um i forgot about naughty girl yeah
what's that like getting the call from
beyonce
man it's dope i mean it was like um
they actually performed like my scene go
off of the leprechaun i can do that they
actually performed there like in houston
at like a big
show back in the day like i forgot what
arena i don't know if it was a toyota
it's like she's always paying homage
when she can you know yeah yeah to this
day nah till his day
till his day yeah but um now that was a
dope a dope moment and then she called
me out the blue and was like hey i want
to
um ship you some of this ivy park so
i got this big box
adidas box delivered and a letter and
you know that was dope and we were labor
mates so it was it's cool so
thank you for the clothes missy's nose
thanks for the clothes miss nose there
it is how should i say respectfully miss
is carter i don't know did she take the
name i don't know but you know you got
to show that
yeah yeah
yeah that you know hey i don't want to
dive into the ti thing because you've
talked about it to the death but i just
i never remember
what was the origin of your guys's issue
back in the day i got a i got a song
with easy to block captain kyle how many
times it's on his album timothy
and um
timothy by the way everyone's saying
that now
and how many times y'all go ask me about
this
there it is
he said go listen to it
[Laughter]
what up we gotta interrupt the interview
real quick to tell you about our people
at blue chew don't forget to go to
bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg right now and
get your first month free all you gotta
do is pay five dollars in shipping it's
the uh man fellas the game changer
that's all i'm gonna say
you pop the blue chew and your dick is
on a million
man i'm not saying it makes it bigger
but it feels bigger i'm just saying i'm
not saying but i'm saying
uh look same active ingredient as cialis
and viagra
minus the awkward visits to the doctor's
office all right it's all over the phone
it's so easy they ship it right to your
door in discrete packaging
uh i don't know if you're going through
erectile dysfunction because you're
stressed out at work
uh maybe uh you just need a little extra
hump with wifey whatever it is maybe you
just want to take a bluetooth and beat
your dick like it stole something just
to feel like
damn that shit's hard bruh you know what
i'm saying go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg right now and you
will save
all money it's free yeah you'll you'll
get a whole month for free
bluechew.com promo code bootleg for a
whole month for free delivered to your
door discreetly no doctor's appointments
no awkward visits same viagra cialis
ingredients
man what are you waiting for go do that
well there it is
we'll change subjects
your viral moment
but the song
expresses it yeah yeah like my verse
starts off look i don't want to talk
about the streets no more and i don't
want to talk about the beef no more
deuce deuce on my head on my hippo you
can meet fo-fo you go to war with a
vampire teeth go show
you know but anyway
what was the question again
i just that was the perfect moment for
me to for you to plug it yeah and then
you use this clip and make to promote
the interview
um no i was just i was just curious um
like like the initial just kind of
conflict like what what did it what was
the origin of of it it was some petty
stuff like me and him we actually have
each other number um we probably text
and uh yeah we talked about me coming on
his podcast and him coming on mine
so we go we go together that would be
dope yeah yeah so we we go scheduling
where we're filming both at the same
time so we talked we had dialogue on it
but
what i will say like it was really super
petty and it was something that i tried
to
nip in the bud before it spiraled out of
control you know i mean because you know
i know how right things can get out of
hand so
i'm just glad that jay prince being the
og that he is
decided to step in and say you know what
like i i can't let two youngsters you
know what i'm saying young cats from the
south yeah two kings
and at the end of the day
we both talked about it laughed about it
and he was like
yeah he was like man we was kids we
so you know it's out to the g but it was
petty and um i've moved past it man it's
beautiful man yeah um
you and zero this is your the you so you
guys have two joint projects we did
kings of the south part one and part
two's coming or part two is coming yeah
and part two is just like music like
kings of south one we was in a different
mode back then it was you know a lot
going on but
part two the fans keep asking because
he's the king of the ghetto right and
i'm the freestyle king you know what i
mean so
and that's one of the big things even
with my movie i'm working on is called
king life
it's about like
people fighting for that one spot but if
you really go back to back in the days
like it was multiple kings this king
ruled this area and this raid of course
of course right so
we're so competitive and hip-hop and
they're not you know where we come from
you want to be the number one guy you
know what i mean but you can be the
number one guy in your section you can
be
so that's what my movie is about like
people coming together you know
everybody want that number one spot but
hey we all can be number one do you
think zero gets enough flowers in terms
of just like
i feel like somehow like he
obviously being incarcerated uh during
uh a lot of that era of h-town but like
in terms of just like his ability as an
artist uh you know he's
obviously a legend in your city and i i
just feel like he never probably got
his
his flowers nationally that he probably
deserves
ah i don't feel like they
play zero music like they need to
right you know what i mean unless you go
to houston and they play but but they
play you know his fan base is crazy no
he's got a crazy fan base for sure and i
feel like
they go see that's why that was one of
the main things
why was so important for me to put free
him on my cover because
a lot of times you know it's a stigma of
when
you get this major deal the record label
you know they change you and you know
you sell your soul right and i believe
in god so
i'm not gonna compromise my manhood my
integrity my moral my morals my
principles for no money right so
that's why all my deals i was able to do
what i wanted to do even with the g unit
mixtape she was asking how i get on that
because when i came to new york i was
saying
if i want to take over new york i need
to rap next to the greats so i was with
dipset on all the cam mixtapes doing
records i'm with g-unit buck was already
my homie
who kid putting me on mixtapes and stuff
like that yep i remember all those tapes
so i had to go in like yeah i want i'ma
show you that there's some people from
houston that don't just rap about
popping trunks and candy paint i rap
about that [ __ ] as well but i know how
to
limit how much i talk about that because
i'm thinking worldwide but on back to
zero i just wanted to go into that g
unit and how did i end up on the
mixtapes because i knew i needed to rap
next to the greats and show them that
somebody in texas can rap
um as well you know what i mean of
course and so but yeah with zero man
that dude bro when we get in the studio
our vibe is like
me and my cousin big shasta me and big t
rest in peace big t he's the one who
sung the hook to want to be a baller he
he died
so those are the three people that
when i get in the studio it's like
you know what i mean magic you know what
i mean i'll let like right
in the way he constructed his melodies
he was actually the first
you know rapper really you know singing
and rapping right you know i mean you
know
shout out to him yeah uh yo i feel like
some did somebody just try sampling
sunshine or just put out like a remix
like a new version of it
am i tripping
man it's funny it's funny it's funny you
said that because i'm trying not to give
away but okay so look what maybe someone
played me
a sampled version of it that it isn't
out yet or something i just feel like
it's about time somebody tries to put
remake sunshine bruh
it's crazy so
it's a two-way part to their story i'm
not gonna say who the artist is but okay
so
on the way out here though
i got a dm and an artist hit me and was
like hey man
i remade what what's your information
what you know what's going on og
and um we exchanged information then he
he called a text i text like hey this is
me like me
then he called mm-hmm you know i'm
saying i just gave the gender huh
so he caught
yeah he called it's a guy it's it's a
guy um so he hit me up and um
he was like man i remade
you know the record
sunshine
or i flipped it you know he was like i
gotta let you hear it
and um we talked a little business or
whatever major artist like a major label
artist rather major major yeah yeah yeah
okay major yeah
yeah
crazy part one of his plaques in this
[ __ ]
but i'll tell you off the air
we will make this a bit if you can get
if you can guess
nope it's not yg nope so you you look
you owe me you owe me seven grams of
some zaza
damn i feel like someone played me a f i
feel like somebody played me a record
and i was like oh some it's about time
someone flipped it did it and it's so
crazy to keep this though
that happened the other day now a year
ago another artist
was working on a project and hit me and
his producer was like hey
it's such a great record and you know
what's crazy about that record is it's
like to this day it still is such a
great gold record that radio stations
have to play
because it's it's like
it's just one of those ones it's like
it's never going to go away yeah and i
love when it come on the way it possess
ladies and stuff
but but the other artists hit me like a
year ago his producing
we i actually had recorded a verse on
that version
so it's two artists that contacted me to
do it the other one i don't know it
didn't come out or whatever whatever but
uh
yo so let me ask you this you're
involved in the metaverse obviously the
crypto [ __ ] just crashed pretty crazy
nfts are crashing like crazy right now
yeah um
what is your like thoughts cause like
obviously somebody like snoop dogg
who's
murdering it right now right i can't
even listen to doggy style on spotify
anymore you got to go buy the nft
i don't even know how to buy a [ __ ]
nfc
um but what are your thoughts just on
the whole metaverse and like
is there a way to take advantage of it
as an artist without worrying about
whether or not the nft market crashes or
like because obviously crypto nft
metaverse they all kind of go hand in
hand but they're also very separate
because i can go home and throw on my
oculus and play a game in the metaverse
and it's not the same thing as you know
so you're obviously doing concerts
you're right you're you're involved in
the metaverse [ __ ] like correct talk
about your involvement in that and just
your thoughts on that whole [ __ ] well
see
a lot of times the communities they have
a problem when a person tries to like
you know take advantage of that when you
try to use
so i believe in using the word like
utilize right
and then i believe in reaching my people
so i'm a painter i paint art yeah i do
shoes skateboards hats
i draw like my jerry my tattoo you know
i mean i draw so
so like
when it comes to art and our people and
you know the percent of people that are
labeled weird because we might
throw on a a
green shirt with a
orange pair of pants right and to the
average eye they'll be like that doesn't
match but when you elevate to a certain
level of being fly
what if you look in the mirror and you
like that [ __ ] that's all i mean that's
all that [ __ ] matters right right so
everybody has
to do something one time to become a
trend right so the metaverse and just
the people that i'm still able to
interact with that are fans and that
you know that are higher thinkers people
that are looking at life from a
different angle they they usually buy
into people that are like them right
and when you have a brand and you're
able to
always show the promoter or the artist
or the fan people that spend money with
me or show that that they support me i
always go out my way to be like thank
you i'm gonna take that extra picture
i'ma give you exotic pop i'ma do you
know whatever the [ __ ] just because you
told me my music got you through this
and that so
i show fans and people love so
people that are there wherever my fans
are or wherever there are people who
strive to surround themselves with great
people and make money and leave
generation of wealth behind for their
family and not be on some dumb [ __ ] not
easily easily
you know swayed you know like right
right i'm creating stuff for people that
are thinkers and coming up with
different ways that people who want to
be involved in the music industry
can invest in other artists like i'm
working on some other apps that's going
to actually help a lot of artists
get investors and and have people around
the world to be able to have
steak in certain things well that's
smart because i always i always because
there's a guy named russell out of uh
vallejo california
so he's doing something similar for his
music he's like yo
if you
you can invest in this song and i give
you a chunk of it from distrokid right
so i feel like for up-and-coming artists
if someone believes in you enough
if there's a place you could point them
to be like yo you can go
purchase a steak in whatever
this album is or whatever and you can
help bankroll what i'm trying to do with
it you know what i'm saying i think that
that's that's a platform that's missing
yeah for independent especially for
independent artists hey and i'm one of
them type of people bro like
i want to leave
music in
better shape
in business in better shape than it was
before i came right like so
if you think about the era that came
before me and the way their contracts
were right right some of them still
became millionaires and some of them
still suck the contracts right contract
stuff right and then think about the
artists that came out before them the
people in the 50s and yeah when they
were getting paid one penny yeah it's
crazy and you know but the cost of
living was way lower right but still it
was so crazy it's still crazy yes wow so
now the the error that came after me in
the era
the artist
they're making a whole bunch of money at
a faster rate you know i mean so
you know money management and just it's
a lot of different things that
you know these artists
should do and and learn to do with their
money and learn how to treat people with
more respect because you never know when
you're gonna see the same people
coming down right you come down yeah
that's real
um yo man houston's obviously in a great
place now two of the biggest artists in
the [ __ ] world of travis and megan um
how do you feel like uh
just the scene locally is doing right
now
outside of those two because obviously
they're [ __ ] out of here but just
like in terms of just like the the
underground scene i guess
man i mean you got
as far as like newer artists you've got
you know south wales sauce walk is
killing it um you got propane
propane's been dope for a while too yep
um
you got maxo cream just put out a crazy
record with bending the butcher exo i'm
trying not to leave you got toby i don't
know how to pronounce his last name so i
i always [ __ ] his name up too so i just
be told he's incredible yeah um
and it it's talent out there man it's a
lot of youngsters omb bloodbath
um a lady named lady isis
it'd be hard can the man's from
she's on the freshman cover mm-hmm so
it's like a it's a lot of artists man i
don't want to [ __ ] forget it's crazy
too because now like i feel like houston
without even i don't feel like we
acknowledge houston is like one of the
big cities st still like right now if
you really look at like who's popping in
hip-hop like
houston is like
and also people love to go to houston
and record
like houston is like a place people
really enjoyed it oh yeah yeah yeah now
a lot of the artists they come out i
know people who just who move there like
a lot of people just live there because
there's no state tax the food's good the
strip clubs are amazing
property the property's not too crazy oh
yeah now that's where you we play
monopoly out there it's real opportunity
like my board game like bro we
that's why we love it where we at yeah
we can
we don't yeah we don't never have to
leave if we never you know wanted to
leave we we would be kind of in the
middle of everything quick flights
atlanta a quick flight to l.a yeah the
hook man and when y'all do go to houston
when y'all do go to houston
turkey leg hook get the alfredo is that
your spot no that's my homie lynn lin
and his wife what's a turkey leg hut yes
hey get the alfredo the shrimp alfredo
turkey leg with the rice that sounds
amazing like it's like stuffed and man
now i'm hungry oh yeah i am too soon as
i get done with this well there it is
look little flip uh new music coming oh
yeah all the freestyle three
coming out of the freestyle three we're
gonna get to some freestyling oh yeah
august 19th different youtube video
definitely after that i'm dropping
funjin philip
and then you know me and zero we got
kings at the south part too
on tonight video is it's out right now
doing numbers check it out flipping zero
fa much love my guy you know what i mean
the homies yes sir
f.a is a good guy man let's get it